SCOTT MCMULLAN: Welcome,
everyone.
My name is Scott McMullan.
I'm the Google Apps Partner Lead
with Google Enterprise.
Welcome to our session.
Thanks for hanging out
with us today.
There's a lot of amazing
sessions happening right now,
so appreciate you attending.
I share the stage today with
three awesome co-presenters,
Cameron Henneke, founder of
GQueues, Jim McNellis, CEO and
founder of Dito, and Matt
Trifirio, SVP of
Marketing at Assistly.
So today's session is going
to be a bit high level.
We're not going to
do a lot of code.
We'll talk a little tech, but
it's mainly around the
Marketplace, and the business
opportunities, and some of the
product opportunities that
exists, as facilitated by the
Marketplace.
So quick housekeeping.
Our feedback link is here.
We'd love your feedback
live as we go.
And hashtags for this are
io2011 and googleapps.
So before we start--
This is not made for
someone my height.
Before we start talking about
the Marketplace, we need to do
a little level set on
what Google Apps is.
How many folks use Google Apps
in their business or--
OK, we've got a few hands
that didn't go up.
So we'll work on that.
So Google Apps is hosted
messaging and
collaboration product.
It consists of things like
Gmail, Google Calendar, Google
Contacts, Google Docs, Google
Video, Google Sites, a whole
suite of applications hosted
by Google serving
customers of all sizes.
So small, medium, and large
businesses, as well as
educational institutions
and governments.
So we've got two price points
for this product.
We have a free edition, which
we give to educational
institutions and nonprofits
and small companies.
And a paid addition.
And that's $50 a user a year.
In fact, I think we just
announced an also monthly
pricing as well, but that's
a paid addition product.
And what we're really happy to
talk about in general is the
context of adoption.
So we've seen really,
really strong
adoption of Google Apps.
It's getting stronger every
month, every quarter.
And these are potential
your customers.
We've got over 30 million
users, and 3 million
businesses, and 3,000 more
signing up each day.
And these folks are getting
core, mission critical
messaging collaboration
applications on
the clock from Google.
And they want a lot more.
So this is the opportunity.
They come asking for us, hey, do
you have this application?
Can you do that application?
How do I do this?
And we say, look, we do
what we've got here.
We've got these great
applications, but we cannot
serve everything.
And that's what you
guys are doing.
You guys are out there
innovating in all kinds of
areas, and so the mission of the
Marketplace is to make it
really easy for those 30 million
users, 3 million
businesses to find more great
web based applications to run
their businesses and
organizations.
And this is across, again,
anything you
guys want to sell.
Anything you guys want to do
based on your expertise and
the markets you're addressing.
You team with us to extend that
Google Apps suite with
your application.
And so we want to make that
easy as a few clicks.
And we'll talk about--
I'll give you a demo of
that in a second.
So that's the basic mission.
That's the basic opportunity is
to work together to serve
those customers.
Before we go into some of the
details, I want to step back
and talk a little bit about
the context of the
Marketplace, and how it fits
in with larger Google
Enterprise.
So 100% web.
That's really a vision and a
strategy we've got that says
simply, in 2011, a business
should be able to run their
entire business using nothing
more than a web browser.
So with that as a mental
model-- we
call that 100% web--
a bunch of things need to come
together to make that happen.
So you need, first of all at
the top, great devices.
You need great physical
devices.
You need great browsers, which
is why we're investing in
Chrome OS and Chrome.
And you certainly great mobile
experiences around, and we're
investing in Android for tablets
and smartphones.
But once you've got access to
a modern browser, you need
obviously apps.
So the three tiers in
the middle here.
So in the left, we've
Google Apps.
These are the applications that
we are selling directly
to customers.
You've got applications that
customers want to build for
themselves.
So IT developers, custom
programmers, SIs, VARs, people
who want to build custom
applications.
We offer Google App Engine
as the platform as
a service for that.
And there's lots of other
great options
out there for that.
But we offer App Engine.
And then the third pillar
here is the Marketplace.
So packaged applications ready
to roll from you all.
And of course, we've got
our investment in the
infrastructure, global
infrastructure for the cloud.
I do want to make one point
here, even though the
Marketplace is sitting on our
platform, App Engine and our
hosting services are not
a requirement to use
Marketplace.
You can host your application
anywhere you want.
So how are we doing?
So the good news is adoption
is growing.
It's growing strongly.
We've got over 300 apps
in the Marketplace.
Today again, these are
web applications.
They may have mobile companions,
but these are
primarily web applications
serving businesses and
educational institutions.
And to give you a sense
of what to expect, in
terms of how much--
What download rate, what
sort of install
rate, as we call it.
The top applications today are
seeing north of 1,000 new
businesses a week.
So these are businesses.
These aren't users.
So one business may have 5
users, may have 50 users, may
have 500 users, but this is an
indication where we are in our
adoption of the Marketplace, and
our customers' discovery
of how these applications
work.
So let me give you a quick demo
just to see the customer
experience.
What it's like for a user to
browse the Marketplace and to
install an application
to their domain.
So here's the homepage.
We've got categories on the
left, different types of
applications.
We also have our partners, our
VARs, our professional
services partners offering
professional services in here.
Featured and notable.
So we do promotions of certain
applications in the center.
Users can scroll through that.
And then some of our
top applications
listed on the right.
So let's just say today
that I'm a Google Apps
administrator.
I'm looking for project
management application.
I hit search.
I've got a bunch of choices.
I'm going to take a quick
look at the first one.
Manymoon, this is one of our
launch partners from a little
over a year ago.
As a user, I can certainly read
about the application.
I can watch videos.
You're free to put a lot of
your collateral and your
marketing materials in here.
I can look at some ratings
reviews, 266.
And let's just say I'm
interested in making this
happen and bringing
this to my users.
So again, I'm an administrator
of a Google Apps domain.
This button right here is where
all the action happens.
So the Add It Now button is
the main call to action.
You want users to click on this,
and it's going to ask
them to log in.
So I need to authenticate
against my domain.
So as an admin, scott@ehit.com
is my personal domain.
So it's a three-step process.
First, there's terms
of service.
So I can review of Manymoon's
terms of service.
These would be your
I can review it here,
agree to continue.
The next step is pretty much
the most important.
So the main premise of these
applications is that they're
not only just listed in a
directory, but they actually
integrate in together.
They build common integrated
features, sharing data,
sharing UI.
So Manymoon happens to be a
highly integrated application.
They integrate with Google Docs,
Google Spreadsheets,
Google Calendar, Contacts,
and e-mail.
And so these are all of the
API endpoints that they're
asking access to.
And so by clicking Grant
Data Access here, as an
administrator, I gave a 2-legged
OAuth data access
grant to Manymoon to access my
domain data listed here.
So that one click goes to--
The Manymoon application and my
domain are now authorized
to speak to each other.
And the final step here to
enable the application.
This gives it all my users in
the universal navigation
language, which I'll show
you in a second.
So that's it.
So we've just taken a suite of
maybe 8 Google Apps, 7 Google
Apps, and we've expanded it by
one to include Manymoon.
So they have their own
settings page.
And I'm going to show you two
quick things again, just to
give you sense of what
the users experience.
On my dashboard page, again,
I can review all the Google
applications here, as well
as a couple Marketplace
applications that I've
gotten installed.
So they're all holistically
given to the admin
to see in one place.
And as it--
Actually let me point out here
that we also do some
promotions.
So one of the benefits to
Marketplace is we get a lot of
information about what the
applications are, and how they
work, and the types of customers
that use them, and
like them, and the different
adoption rates.
So we're starting to take these
applications out of the
Marketplace browsing experience,
and bring them
into other experiences
where users lives.
So in this case, it's
the dashboard.
I'm an admin.
I have four applications
recommended for me that I can
either click on and add them
immediately, or I can go and
visit their page in
the Marketplace.
So where it's not just about
going and sending people to
Marketplace, we want to make
sure that recommendations and
personalization work really
well for users.
So let me flip over to one
last bit to my Inbox.
So as a user, I can take a look
here in the upper left,
and I certainly can browse to my
calendar, Google Docs, what
have you, but now I've got in
the More menu, I've got links
to apps from the Marketplace.
Here's Manymoon.
I click on that, and
I'm logged in.
The other thing I actually
haven't mentioned yet is that
the single sign on is a core
experience for all Marketplace
applications.
So that need to--
No need to provision,
create extra
counts, add user passwords.
Every Marketplace app comes
with a single sign on
experience at a minimum.
And this is done through OpenID,
which is something
that you all would need
to develop to.
So that's a quick tour of
installing an application.
Let me flip back to
the presentation.
So how does this work?
So the first thing, of course,
build your application.
Again, this can be an existing
application that you are
selling in market for the last
month, year, 10 years, brand
new applications, whatever.
But you build it on the stack of
your choice, no dependency
on App Engine.
Of course, we love App Engine,
but no dependency there.
The second, and the most
interesting part-- and I think
some of our co-presenters will
talk about this-- is the
integration.
Again, this is not a directory
of applications on the web.
These are directory of
applications that have the
ability to do online
provisioning, and most
importantly, offer an
integrative experiences.
And we have a couple more talks
to really drill into how
to create those integrative
experiences in the APIs later
on today and tomorrow.
So I encourage you
to attend those.
But this is the step where you
would start to work on making
those customers love our
applications together.
And so again, the first one,
single sign on is a
requirement.
All applications must become
OpenID reliant parties.
And then we have well over a
dozen APIs for all of our
applications beyond that, where
you guys can optionally
choose to create integrated
features.
And then sell.
The whole point is we're
trying to take existing
applications and sell them to
3 million businesses, 30
million users, and
increasingly engage our resellers.
We have over 2,000 valuated
retailers who are trained on
Google Apps.
They're selling Google Apps.
They're deploying
their training.
And they are increasingly
looking to add additional
applications to their
portfolios.
And they're looking to
Marketplace for a great source
of complementary application.
So this is an opportunity we'll
be talking about more
later on this year.
But it's already happening
today.
And I think Jim will actually
talk a little bit about this
in his session.
So what do we ask?
We ask for two things.
$100 fee.
So anti-spam fee.
Think of that as making sure
you are really you.
And you can make one or more
listings to the Marketplace
after paying us $100.
And then 20% recurring
revenue share.
This is where we ask to share
20% revenue you would get for
any new customers that you
acquire through the
Marketplace.
Your existing customers could
come in use these
integrations, no problem.
New customers that we help
you get, when they
pay, we'll share 20%.
And we're going to implement
this through a billing API,
which is actually not
yet released.
We're still working on it.
So we're in exemption
mode right now.
No one's paying rev share to
date, all 300 applications.
But that's coming out
later on this year.
So in terms of how this
works for developers.
Again, build, integrate,
list and sell.
Let's talk a little bit more
about the integration step.
We use a manifest file to
essentially describe the set
of integrations that you've done
with our application in
our application.
So things like terms of service,
where does that live?
Support URL, simple stuff.
But then the API endpoints that
you want to access, you
list them here as API scopes,
in addition to your OpenID
information.
So this all gets declared
in a simple XML file.
And then when you're ready to
actually start to test it, and
start to get it out to users,
two more forms to fill.
First is you're going
to become a vendor.
And that's where that
$100 fee comes in.
Name, address, company
name, logo.
But then you create a listing,
and this is your application.
This is your marketing page,
your homepage on the
Marketplace.
All your collateral goes in
here, but then that manifest
file in the lower left, that's
where you paste that in.
So once you do that,
you hit save, and
you've got your page.
You can make sure you like it,
make sure it looks good.
Of course, add it now and
start to test the
provisioning process.
When you first save
it, is not live.
You get to tweak it into
your heart's desire.
When you're ready to
actually engage
customers, you publish it.
And that tells our application
approval team to
take a look at it.
We'll look, and we have a
lightweight vetting process to
make sure that you have OpenID
implemented, that there's no
bugs, and our basic terms of
service are adhered to.
And then we'll approve it.
3 to 5 business days right
now is the current time.
And then you're live.
Then you're launched.
And that's where things
obviously get interesting.
We want to get to that point
as soon as possible.
So let me just run through a
couple more things around the
acquisition process, and what
it looks like to engage
customers, and some of the
promotions that we do for the
Marketplace.
So the first basic tip is don't
skip your launch marketing.
You may be an application,
again, that exists, and you've
been selling for years.
But these are new users.
These are 3 million new
businesses that may not have
heard of your application, and
maybe you have new features.
So make sure that you give them
a proper launch to get
yourself visibility within that
group beyond just being
in the Marketplace.
So high quality listing page,
landing pages on your sites,
blogging, tweeting, press
outreach, based on your intent
and budget.
But this is something that
we really highly
recommend you not skip.
And then after you're live,
what do you expect?
So pretty high level, but this
is really nothing different
than what you do today
on your own website.
So it's a funnel.
Listing pageviews.
You can plug your analytics
code into your Marketplace
listing to get some intelligence
about referrers,
and pageviews, and
things like that.
Tracking the Add It Now call
to action, and then driving
app usage and covering to paid
is really where a lot of the
work goes from an execution
standpoint.
And again, I think some of my
co-presenters have some
interesting tidbits
to share here.
So that's a super quick
tour of Marketplace--
what it is up to what customers
are using it and
engaging with you.
In terms of our promotion, the
big value add here is that
we're going to not only provide
this platform for
integration, but we're going to
make sure people know about
the Marketplace and
drive usage.
So we do that in a
handful of ways.
And we're always looking for
creative ideas, and looking to
get better at this.
So first one, the first major
way we do promotion, is in our
products themselves.
So as you saw, whether it's in
the upper left, or we have a
Find More Services link, if
you're in the universal
navigation, that will get
to the Marketplace.
Our Setup Wizard,
which launched a
couple of months ago.
All new customers come through
this and essentially walk
through a wizard to set
up Google Apps.
And there's a very explicit area
where we talk about the
Marketplace, what it is, and
recommend some applications to
that user, right in
that set up flow.
And of course, I just showed
you in the dashboard.
So admins who go to the
dashboard will see recommended
apps right now.
Of course, the format may
change, and we're going to
always to tune this.
But the main take away here is
that we're selling into a
group of users, who are using
Google Apps and clearly want
and have requested more.
And so we're trying to get
better and better at taking
things in the Marketplace that
are great, and helping people
discover them while they're
using our products, as well as
just shopping the Marketplace.
So that includes our
products site.
We drive a lot of users here,
of course to educate them
about our products and part
of our core product is--
One of our pillars is the
Marketplace you see will help
educate customers about what's
there in the lower left.
We do Adwords campaigns.
We love Adwords.
People are searching.
We take out campaigns around
keywords that relate to Google
Apps, drive traffic to
categories, drive traffic to
search terms that may
essentially surface your
application in that
search term.
And we do all that good stuff,
blogging and tweeting.
We have a YouTube channel, where
you can host a video of
your application working
with ours.
And of course, the press.
So back to the 100% web.
We're really--
The mission is to get customers
excited, to get
customers to adopt, and really
help benefit their business.
And so to the extent that you
have interesting customer
stories, we should be sharing
these stories and helping not
only bloggin and tweeting about
them, but also engaging
the press and making sure the
press understands what it
looks like as these businesses
are moving more and more of
their business to the cloud.
So that's it for me.
Get to the real meat, the real
content of the presentation,
I'd like to invite up Cameron.
CAMERON HENNEKE:
Thanks, Scott.
Hello, my name is
Cameron Henneke.
I'm the founder and
CEO of GQueues.
First, today I'll tell you a
little bit about GQueues, and
why we joined the Marketplace.
Then we'll go to a quick demo,
and I'll follow it up with
some Marketplace tips.
So back in 2008, I decided it
was time to move my paper
to-do list to the cloud.
I tried several products, and
found them either overly
complex, or simple yet lacking
the features I
needed to stay organized.
So I did what most developers
do in this situation, I set
out to create something new.
GQueues is an online task
manager that people use to
actually get things done.
So it's simple, yet powerful,
has just the right
features you need.
Basically no learning curve.
And it integrates with other
products you use day to day.
As you'll see, GQueues is
very Google-centric.
It's built on App Engine, using
Python and uses almost
all of the service provided
by that platform.
Users can log in with Gmail
or Google Apps.
And it uses a number of other
Google data APIs as well.
So why did we join
the Marketplace?
GQueues was started about a year
before the Marketplace
launched, and already
offered Google
Apps login using OpenID.
So when I first heard about the
Marketplace from Scott,
the decision to join was really
easy for several reasons.
First, integration
is really simple.
It took very little investment
on my part, in terms of
development time and testing,
to get GQueues listed on the
Marketplace.
If your app already supports
OpenID, basically integration
is just one step--
writing the manifest XML file,
as Scott showed you earlier.
Secondly though,
the Marketplace
serves a great audience.
GQueues already targeted
consumers using Google
products, and with the
Marketplace, I was able to
reach 30 million business
customers
using Google products.
And these customers already
realized the benefits of
software as a service.
And they're willing to pay for
products that integrate with
Google Apps.
So by listing on the
Marketplace, GQueues gained
access to a huge audience that
is essentially predisposed to
buying the service.
So let's check out a demo now,
and we'll see how it works.
So you came to Google IO, and
you had a lot of fun.
And you learned a bunch
of cool new things.
Let's pretend that you're
responsible for planning the
lessons learned meeting for your
group when they get back
from the conference.
So you have your e-mail
opened here.
And you can just click on
GQueues and start planning
your tasks.
There's basically two tasks
you need to do.
The first is to book
a meeting room.
And the second, of course,
is to order lunch food.
And we'll go ahead and assign
this to our coworker Julie.
And we can create a couple
subtasks too,
just so we don't forget.
Now, the tasks here with
dates automatically
show up on your calendar.
So pull that up here.
The Google Calendar API is
used for integration.
And GQueues actually supports
two way syncing, so you can
change the task from the
calendar itself.
Actually we should probably
order lunch food on Thursday.
And if we go back here and
refresh, we see that the task
has been updated with
the new date here.
So you just saw how easy it is
to create a list of tasks
within GQueues itself.
But a lot of times our work
comes to us through e-mail.
So let's switch back
here to e-mail.
And here's a new message
which requires action.
You need to invite the
new hires to the
lessons learned meeting.
So you can actually go down here
to the GQueues gadget,
and we'll transform this
e-mail into a task.
And choose our lessons learned
list. And we'll just say,
invite new hires.
And there we go.
And then we can archive
this e-mail to get
it out of our Inbox.
Or let's say a task just
pops into your head.
You can actually record it
by chatting with GQueues.
If we pull up chat
here, you need to
submit conference receipts.
The item's been added.
We'll switch back to GQueues.
First we'll refresh
lessons learned.
There's the new task that we
created out of the e-mail.
And there's a link to the
email for reference.
And then if we go to our Inbox,
here's the task that we
chatted, and we can just drag
that to our to-do list. And
there we go.
So that's just a quick overview
of GQueues, and some
of its Google product
integrations.
Flip back here.
Let's talk about tips
for the Marketplace.
You saw from Scott earlier how
easy it is to get your apps
listed on the Marketplace with
the required single sign on
integration.
My number one tip for being
successful on the Marketplace
is to add as many integration
points as possible with other
Google products.
And this has benefits
on many levels.
First, it's great
for the user.
If your service works seamlessly
with other products
that they already use, then
there's no learning
required for them.
For instance, Google Calendar
users already know how to drag
and drop events around.
So dragging GQueues tasks around
just seems intuitive.
No learning required.
Integration also increases
user adoption within the
organization.
So having your app listed in the
navigation menu, it really
does make it easy for anyone
within a company to discover
your app, and to test it out.
So this all seems intuitive, but
how do I know that users
want integration?
Back when GQueues was in beta,
I actually surveyed users to
find out which features were
most important to them.
By far the number one feature
was Google Calendar
integration, followed
by sharing
lists with their contacts.
So I put these features in the
full version of GQueues.
Users can do almost everything
else for free in GQueues Lite,
whether it's create subtasks or
tagging, repeating tasks,
published lists.
But if they want the
integration, they have to pay,
and they do.
If you look here at the
difference between GQueues
Lite and the full version,
almost all the premium
features here relate
to integration.
Google Calendar, Contacts,
Gmail.
People value products
that work with
their existing tools.
So secondly, more integration
helps your apps listing in the
Marketplace itself.
Each listing here has a set of
icons that represent the
product integration.
So customers can easily see
how closely your app works
with others.
A deeply integrated app
means their users are
going to save time.
Plus customers can search the
Marketplace based on product
integrations.
So the more you have, the
broader your presence in the
Marketplace.
Lastly and most obvious,
integrating with existing
products speeds up
development.
So sure, I could have
created a separate
calendar system for GQueues.
This would have taken a lot of
development time, not to
mention the fact that users
don't want yet another
calendar that they
have to check.
So since Google Calendar exists,
it's been field tested
by millions of users worldwide,
it really just make
sense to build on top
of this work.
Plus, since GQueues was built
on App Engine, adding
integration is even easier.
For instance, App Engine has
XMPP services built in, so the
GQueues chat bot that I demoed,
it really only took me
about two days to develop
and test.
So how has the Marketplace
helped?
GQueues is based on
a premium model.
So an important metric to look
at is conversion rate.
And the average conversion rate
for a typical premium
product is between 3% and 5%.
So I pulled data for GQueues
from the past 10 months, and
for all the regular channels,
the average
conversion rate was 6.4%.
That's from free users
to paid subscribers.
So a little bit higher
than expected.
But the GQueues users from the
Marketplace convert at a rate
of 30.3%, which is huge.
I said earlier that the
Marketplace really targets an
audience that is ready to buy.
And I think the data
backs this up.
So conversion rate is great,
but how much traffic do I
actually get from
the Marketplace?
So in addition to the
Marketplace, GQueues gets new
users from its own website, the
Google Chrome Web Store,
and a bunch of word of
mouth referrals.
Looking at the data from the
same 10 month period, it turns
out that 27% of all GQueues
users are acquired via the
Marketplace.
So this is not a majority,
but it's still a
very substantial channel.
And when you combine that data
with the conversion rate of
the last line, and you do all
the math, you'll see that the
Marketplace is actually
responsible for 63% of all
paid GQueues users.
So this is a very impressive
number.
And I must say that I'm quite
pleased with the results I've
seen on the Marketplace
so far.
So just to recap, in case you're
looking to follow a
similar path.
Create a product that solves
a real problem for users.
Integrate with their
existing tools.
And lastly, join the Marketplace
to gain access to
a targeted and growing
audience.
If you have questions for me,
I'll be in the Sandbox today
and tomorrow.
Thank you very much.
And I'll turn it over now
to Jim with Dito.
[APPLAUSE]
JIM MCNELLIS: Thanks, Cameron,
that was great.
Hi, my name is Jim McNellis.
I am the CEO and founder
of Dito.
We established ourselves in
2007 as a web design firm.
I immediately set up Google Apps
for my own domain, and I
realize I got into the
wrong business.
And so for the next year and a
half, I actually worked on
creating a business
around providing
Google Apps to customers.
I'm one of the resellers that
Scott mentioned earlier.
So we've been a Google Apps
authorized reseller since
October 2008.
We were one of the first, and
now there's thousands.
We also have 100% certified
Google Apps deployment team,
which means that our deployment
team has been
certified by Google to deploy
Google Apps to customers.
So we're bringing customers to
the Marketplace essentially.
We're creating customers
for this Marketplace.
In addition to being a reseller,
we're also an ISV.
And we were a launch partner
for the Google Apps
Marketplace last year.
And we're in the Sandbox again
this year, so if you do have
any questions for me about our
application after this, you
can feel free to come
check us out.
But basically, we were working
with customers setting them up
on Google Apps.
And they were coming and telling
us the things that
they wanted to Google
Apps to do.
And there weren't a lot of
applications at this time that
were serving that, so we set
out to develop our own
application called
Dito Directory.
And Dito Directory is basically
a contact manager
for Google Apps customers.
It's built for Google
Apps customers.
It's built on App Engine, and
it lives in the Google Apps
Marketplace.
It's very Google-y.
And essentially, our customers
came to us and said, Jim, we
like the Contacts in Google, but
we really want to be able
to share our groups of contacts
with other people in
our organization.
And we can't do that today
in Google Apps.
So what we set out to do is to
develop a interface in order
to allow users to go in and
share their existing contact
groups with other users
in their organization.
Let me show you that
real quick.
This is actually a demonstration
of our upcoming
version of Dito directory.
Today we have an older version
in the Marketplace.
On this version, we'll
be launching
sometime in the next month.
This functionality
is brand new.
If you're interested in testing
out ahead of time,
again, come check us out in the
Sandbox, we'll be able to
give you advanced access.
But so today, what I want to do
is I just want to take this
group of---
Let me refresh the
page real quick.
I just want to take a group of
contacts and I want to share
with another user in
my organization.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go ahead and click on
the Google IO group.
And I just want to make sure
this is the right group, so I
have these four users in here.
And I'm going to add Rene.
Save the group.
And you can see that Rene is
listed here as having the
group shared with him.
So now I'm just going
to go really
quickly, sign in as Rene--
the demo gods are out, huh?
Here we go.
Navigate to my mailbox.
And we'll go into Rene's
contacts, and we should see in
just a moment--
There we go.
Google IO.
And we will see these four
contacts in here.
So we sync these contacts up.
The synchronization will
continue to happen if I change
my contacts.
It'll update on Rene's side.
So it's just a quick
demonstration of what our
application does.
Now I want to talk to you a
little bit about some tips on
the Marketplace that we've
learned since we launched on
the Marketplace, and
specifically around ratings
and reviews.
Ratings and reviews
tell a story.
So what I have here is that
I have two lines today.
The red line is the rating, and
where it starts out is the
highest rate you can get.
That's a five star rating.
And then I have a relative line
for the number of pro
versions of our Dito
Directory sold.
You can see here that in the
beginning, we had started out
with some really great reviews,
and we had an uptick
in our sales.
And then shortly thereafter,
sometime in November, we
released a new version that
didn't really work that great.
And our customers told us that
it didn't work that great and
via the reviews on
the Marketplace.
And then we noticed that our
sales actually shadowed that.
About a month later,
our sales dropped.
And we worked really hard to
improve those reviews and to
work on the problems that were
brought up in those reviews.
And as a result, our reviews
started to rise back up.
And as a result of that, our
sales also have gone back to
about normal.
So we're today at a four star
rating on the Marketplace.
We started out with a
five star rating.
So reviews are really
important.
And so people leave reviews.
You don't get to choose what
reviews they leave you.
You can only develop a great
product and hope that people
leave an appropriate review.
But you can manage
your reviews.
And what do I mean by that?
So first of all, negative
reviews.
When you see a negative review,
one thing we do is to
reach out to the customer, and
we try to solve the problem.
And then once we solve their
problem, we ask them to go
back and amend their review.
They can just basically
edit their review.
If they're already on there, the
Marketplace is smart, and
knows they've already left
a review for you.
So they go back, and they
amend their review.
So we're successful with
that sometimes.
And that definitely helps bring
your average back up.
It erases that negative
review essentially.
And of course, another way
that you can reach your
customers is there's several
different times where you can
ask them to review you--
after they purchased your app
and used it for a period of
time, after you've provided
some level support for the
application, and then of course
if they've given you
that positive feedback via phone
or e-mail, asking them
to go to the Marketplace
and review you.
And we just suggest having a
nice templated instructions
available explaining exactly how
to leave those reviews in
the Marketplace, just to
make it really easy
for them to do it.
But reviews are very
important.
And we've had the exact impact
of having negative reviews and
having our sales drop
off a cliff.
So have a lot of experience
with working with those
reviews as well.
Also as Cameron mentioned
earlier, typical premium is
somewhere between 3% and 5%.
Dito Directory has actually
converted much
better, around 12.5%.
So we're not actually listed
anywhere else.
The only place we list our
application is on the
Marketplace.
And this is representative of
since the 1st of the year.
And there's another thing
we really like about the
Marketplace, and that is that
we get a lot of traffic.
The web is all about getting
people to look at your
products and services.
And the Marketplace provides
us with an excellent
destination on the web
for our products and
professional services.
So you can see here, this is
since the beginning of this
year, we've had approximately
10,000
visitors to our website.
We've had a little bit more
than that to our Dito
Directory listing on
the Marketplace.
So just that one listing for
our application alone
overshadows all of our
professional services and
listings on our own website,
which has a
pretty good page rank.
It's page rank 5.
It's listed very well in
the search engine.
So just want to point
out here--
And then this last bar here
actually shows, we have our
professional services, where
Scott touched on very briefly,
listed on the Marketplace
as well.
So there's 8 other listings in
our Dito Directory listing.
We've had at least three times
the amount of traffic that we
have on our own website.
So we get a lot more eyeballs
on our product and on our
services just from the Google
Apps Marketplace.
And so what does this mean?
This means that this
is a place that--
Google Apps Marketplace is a
place where us as a reseller
are pointing our customers to
go purchase third party
applications when they tell us
they need something that
Google Apps doesn't fit.
And it also means that it's a
place for me, as a vendor, to
list our applications,
and then people--
It gives us credibility
as a vendor in
the Google Apps ecosystem.
That's all I have for today.
Now I'm going to turn you over
to Matt, and he's going to
tell you Assistly.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TRIFIRO: Thank you, Jim.
This is Dan Stern from
Assistly also.
I'm Matt Trifiro, so he's going
to drive my demo in a
few minutes.
I'm the SVP Marketing
of Assistly, and--
So what is Assistly?
Assistly is a all-in-one
customer service system.
Plug it into your website, and
start wowing your customers on
e-mail, live chat, self service
FAQ, social media
channels, like Facebook and
Twitter, and even phone.
And it is everything you need
to provide support.
So why do we choose to enter the
Google Apps Marketplace?
The first thing is Google has
done the heavy lifting of
finding some terrific
customers.
We're a business to business
application.
We're an enterprise
grade application.
We target small to medium
sized enterprises.
B2B lead generation is
really, really hard,
and it's really expensive.
So Google has provided this
environment of highly
targeted, ready to
buy customers.
The people that use Google
Apps have already made a
decision to use it throughout
the organization.
And they're looking to leverage
that investment.
And so they go to the Google
Apps Marketplace to find those
opportunities to leverage it.
Gmail is the number one
application used in the Google
Apps Suite.
So if you like Assistly, and
you integrate with e-mail,
you're golden.
It's an absolutely powerful
way of tapping
into that user base.
And then finally, people that
use Google Apps tend to have a
company wide mindset.
And so for a company like
Assistly that believes in
collaborative support delivering
to customers, that
having that hard work already
done of convincing an
organization that they should
deploy tools throughout their
organization saves a lot of time
and energy and effort to
argue that.
So customer service doesn't
get siloed in the service
organization.
It's actually distributed
throughout the entire
organization.
And because we to sell by the
user, it ends up being higher
ring totals for our customers.
So look, Gmail is a great tool
for support when you're tiny.
But as soon as you start hitting
any volume, you get a
dozen or two e-mails from
your customers a day.
You have maybe a few people
trying to provide support
within your team.
It's not the right tool
for the task.
It tends to break down.
So you go to Google Apps
Marketplace, you'll find a
tool like Assistly.
You notice it's got
five star reviews.
People love the product.
You hit the Add Now button.
And we've done some really
neat things in this on
boarding process.
Now we skipped a couple strings
just to make the demo
tolerable, but there's a good
series of the terms of service
and the authentication
on the Google side.
But as soon as you get into our
on boarding process, we
query the Google API to
find your site domain.
So we populate the site that
says where you go to use
Assistly, and then we actually
do another query.
And we pull up all the users on
your system, and lets you
check off users that you want
invite to collaborate with you
on your support to trial the
product, to use the product.
And then again, because we
wanted to be an instant wow
experience for customers that
are trying Assistly, we look
to try to find an e-mail box
that's probably the support
Inbox, support@mycompany.com
or help@mycompany.com.
We automatically populate
that in the box.
We make it one click to hook
that channel up and import
your existing e-mails.
And then again, we've got other
channels like the social
media channels that are one
or two clicks away.
And then you're done.
You're in Assistly as soon
as you enable it.
This is the collaborative
agent desktop.
It's optimized for customer
support work flow.
All of your customer inquiries
from all your channels,
whether it be social media, or
e-mail, or phone, or organized
in priority order.
You can click on any
one of them.
And you've got all the tools
you need to handle your
customer inquiries.
You have customer records.
You have all the history
of that customer.
You have any status
Every case has a priority.
Every case has an owner.
Every case has a status.
And that means you have this
air tight capability for
providing support.
Yet it's an interface that
looks a lot like e-mail.
So you tend to have the
familiarity that you normally
get from that.
That's it.
That's for the demo.
[LAUGHING]
Yeah, the sneaker net.
So I have two tips for
the Marketplace.
The first one is, there are a
lot of applications on the
Marketplace.
Scot mentioned 300.
Spend a good part of a day
actually installing
applications and trying
them out.
There are some that have really
terrific worked flows,
and others that don't have
such terrific work flows.
Some of the product listing
pages are a
lot better than others.
Some of them are very careful
to rank for the right SEO
terms in the Marketplace,
which is important.
People are searching.
Some are written really well.
Got great copywriting.
So identify the ones you think
are the best practices, look
at the applications that are
successful in the Marketplace,
and really spend the time to
study the on boarding process
to identify how you can make it
easier for your customer to
get to that moment of wow
as fast as they can when
installing your application.
And then tap your community.
One of my favorite application
installations was by Tungle.me.
I wrote a love note to the
CEO, ended up spending 20
minutes on the phone with him,
gave me some absolutely
terrific tips.
It's still a small community.
And I found you can reach out
to people, and get some some
great advice.
And then don't forget
your analytics.
There's an ability to add Google
Analytics profile to
your listing page.
Absolutely create that profile
and add that page.
And then treat your listing page
and all the links on that
page like you would any
other campaign.
And attach Google UTM codes.
If you don't know what that is,
Google it and find out.
But you can attach tracking
codes to your links.
Because that's how you
figure out where the
value is coming from.
And that's how you justify your
return on investment in
the Marketplace.
And I'll give you one
clear example.
So you look at this page,
you say, well,
where's the money button?
Well, it's this one.
Yes, of course, that's where
the money comes from.
But it's also at this link.
Because people click
that link, and they
come to your website.
And this link?
Same thing.
And these two links that
come to your website.
And because we've coded all
those to track them from
Google Apps Marketplace, what
we found is that in addition
to all the great business that
Google Apps Marketplace was
bringing us directly through the
Add It Now button, we also
had another 30% lift.
So there was another 30%
additional customers that were
finding about Assistly from the
Google Apps Marketplace,
but were becoming our customers
through some other mechanism.
Or at least trying the product
And so we're getting this
additional justification for
participation in the
Marketplace.
And we're absolutely thrilled
with the support that Google
has given us, and with the
success in the Marketplace.
So it's been a absolutely
terrific channel for us within
the first--
We've been on the Marketplace a
little over 60 days now, and
within the first three days,
it was one of our top five
performing channels.
So like I mentioned earlier,
terrific community.
I've done a lot of applications
for a lot of
different platforms. Had
relationships with a lot of
different developer
relationships.
Google's is world class.
We've been able to get our
technical questions answered.
We've got great support
on the marketing side.
Absolutely world class.
And then a ton of indirect
benefits.
The traffic and visibility to
Assistly that's brought to us
from the Marketplace, in
addition to the lift of
organic sign ups that we saw,
that we can attribute, at
least partially back to our
presence in the Google Apps
Marketplace.
So thank you, and I think
Scott's got some Q&A here.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT MCMULLAN: All right,
thanks, guys.
Awesome presentations.
Thank you for sharing.
So we're going to go into Q&A
for the next 13 or so minutes
we've got left.
You've got a question for any
of us up here, please--
Actually if could come to the
mic, that would be great.
AUDIENCE: Hi, as someone on
the Marketplace, these are
some great tips, great
advice, thank you.
Quick question, Scott you
mentioned about billing.
You said that if you acquire
users Apps Marketplace, then
you pay the 20% recurring.
If you don't, then you don't.
So is it just fine to have
people using your gadget or
your connection points if
they're paying you somewhere
else as long as they weren't
acquired on the page?
In other words, you get all the
integration, even if the
billing didn't come
from there?
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Great
question.
And we are a little bit light
on the details here, so in
general, billing through the
Marketplace will eventually be
a requirement.
So when we have our billing
APIs, and they're fully rolled
out-- and there will be a grace
period-- but you will
need to adopt to billing
APIs when that we put
out, when they come.
Is that--
AUDIENCE: And I didn't
mean to--
I know that you guys are
changing billing stuff.
I wasn't as much referring
to that.
It's more just the
acquisition part.
In other words, you can
always have a free
product, I'm guessing.
And there's definitely
a paid version.
But are you saying that if you
have a paid version, and they
use your market thing, then the
pay will go through you?
SCOTT MCMULLAN: It's
for new customers.
So your existing--
Customers can come and add the
additional integration, using
the Add It Now button, that
provisioning flow.
And there's no rev share for
their existing customers.
If they're new to you, then
there is a rev share.
AUDIENCE: I guess, it's just
to me, the whole idea of
what's new.
I might have a customer, but you
don't know whether they're
new or not when they click
the Add It Now button.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: So
yeah, we'll--
So in the terms of service say
new, we don't define it as new
in the last second, in the last
day, it's a good point.
But in general, the spirit
of it is new.
So literally if they just came
through and said, hey, this is
a great application, let
me check it out.
That's a new customer.
If they were a customer a month
ago, and they come to
the Marketplace and say,
I would also like--
I'm now a Google Apps customer,
and I'd like to hook
these two things up.
That's an existing customer.
AUDIENCE: So somewhere or
another, there's some sort of
trusting in there.
It's not necessarily--
Just because they--
Because for example, in iTunes,
it doesn't matter
where you came from, you pay.
Whereas here you're saying,
there's some fuzziness about
where the customer came from.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Correct.
And we'll try it de-fuzz that
as we launch it out.
Thanks
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm Tim.
We are a Google Apps partner and
distributor in Chile and
Latin America.
We're also developing apps
now for the Marketplace.
And one thing that was very
interesting I found was, what
you guys mentioned about
the conversion
rates to paying customers.
Because one thing is that you
drive traffic and you say, the
Google Apps--
I don't know who said it.
The Google Apps customers
that use the Marketplace
are ready to pay.
That makes them more
qualified to get
higher conversion rates.
Have you--
I just wanted to see if you
can go into more detail--
each one of you-- and just
really quickly, if there's a
big difference in percentages
of the Google Apps customers
and the premium users
of Google Apps.
So those that are already paying
for Google Apps, versus
the guy said are using
the free version.
Have you done any and
analysis on that?
So that would be very
interesting.
So somebody uses Google Apps
free edition is likely to
convert that 10%, but somebody
who is already using premium
edition is already paying.
Should be easier, right?
JIM MCNELLIS: Yeah, so I can
answer that really quickly.
From our experience, our
application actually
interfaces with APIs that are
only available with the
business edition
of Google Apps.
So all of our customers, our
actually paying customers are
premiere edition customers, are
business edition customers.
So they have already paid
for the application.
CAMERON HENNEKE: Yeah, for
GQueues, I don't have the
stats on the differences between
maybe the free Google
Apps users versus premium.
But I do know that a large
majority of my customers,
they're smaller businesses
between, I don't
know, 5 and 25 users.
And a lot of those then are
falling under the free Google
Apps, and they seem to
be converting just
as much as the paying.
So for us, we haven't
seen a difference.
If they're on Google Apps, and
they want products, then
they'll pay for them, even if
they're not paying for Google
Apps itself.
MATT TRIFIRO: Yeah, we've only
been in the Marketplace for 60
days, so I don't have
statistically relevant data.
We're seeing a pretty uniform
conversion rate though, so
we'll see if that holds out as
we get more conversions.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank,
everybody.
Great tips.
Good follow on question actually
around who you're
seeing around the Marketplace.
I'm curious--
You mentioned small
businesses.
I'm curious what the mix is
between very small business
range that you mentioned versus
the larger, midsize or
enterprise companies.
And also the mix you're
seeing between--
All your tools have a lot
of end user appeal.
I'm curious what you're seeing
between the admin and the end
user appeal, and how you're
bridging that divide.
Or maybe the companies are so
small that it doesn't make a
difference.
MATT TRIFIRO: OK, so
I'll take a stab.
I think I understand.
So the first question--
I forgot the first question.
AUDIENCE: Company size.
MATT TRIFIRO: So company size.
So essentially targets companies
that are between 15
and 150 employees, which means
their support staff is 5, 10,
15, 20, and so on.
We get a pretty wide range of
company sizes, and so Assistly
license sizes from the Google
Apps Marketplace.
I would say a fairly meaningful
percentage-- again,
I'm talking about small
sample sizes still--
are in that organization size
that's a 150 or less.
But I'm not seeing all of them
being on the free tier of
Google Apps.
I'm seeing a pretty wide mix.
We've got some fairly sizable
customers from the Google Apps
Marketplace.
That's another reason this
is exciting to us.
What was the second question?
AUDIENCE: Just the mix between,
especially for those
larger companies, the admin who
actually needs to do the
Add It Now--
MATT TRIFIRO: Yeah, that's
a great question.
So I don't--
So the question, I think, is
the admin may not be the
actual consumer of
the application.
OK, so Assistly is
a good example.
So you're a large
organization.
Your customer service
organization might be 20% of
your overall organization.
The customer service manager
is probably not the admin.
Well, I think--
This is my hypothesis.
I don't know the answer.
But I think part of what
accounts for the 30% lift that
I showed you are people that
are in the customer service
organization.
They aren't the administrator,
but they might be the decision
maker, or certainly a key
influencer, are finding us on
the Marketplace but don't have
the admin privileges.
So they're coming to our
website, signing up through
our normal process.
What I don't know yet is to
see if those folks go back
with the administrator
and actually sign up.
I've seen that happen once.
But I'll have to see if
there's a trend there.
But I think that is an
interesting question how we
should solve it.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Just to add to
that topic, so definitely
we're very well aware that the
buyer isn't always the admin.
And we released and rolled
out a feature that lets a
non-admin notify their admin.
That's a small step to making
that flow easier, but we're
working on also other ways
to enable all buyers.
JIM MCNELLIS: Yeah, I just want
to add that we definitely
see a variety of customers,
small and large.
I think most of them are
smaller customers, just
because most of the customers
on Google Apps are smaller
customers in general.
So a large majority of them
are smaller customers.
Our tool is actually an
admin-focused tool.
We do have end user
capabilities, but we're
actually targeting the admin
in the admin tools section.
So it's definitely used more
by admins than end
users, in our case.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Thanks
for the question.
MATT TRIFIRO: I just want to
add something to that.
If you have an application that
has targeted the smaller
organization, you've actually
got this triple benefit.
Because the person who does the
install also tends to be
the decision maker.
And so these 30 to 50--
50 employees or fewer,
that's often
concentrated in one person.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, guys,
for the great tips.
We are actually a Google Apps
Marketplace vendor.
I have a couple of suggestions
about one of the things that
we find difficulties to get
support for technical aspects
of our application, especially
when we work
with enterprise customers.
We tend to send e-mails
to general support.
We wonder would be great if
there is a special channel
where Marketplace vendors can
have a better support through
technical support or other
stuff that would be very
interesting.
Is there anything like that
planned or what are your
thoughts about that?
Because some of you, you
probably have your
applications running.
Do you get a special channel?
Or if there are technical issues
or critical issues, do
you get appropriate support?
And how do you actually deal
with those things when they're
really critical?
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Just to clarify,
are these typically
questions with the purchase
process of the Marketplace, or
things like APIs being slow or
not working the way you expect
them there?
AUDIENCE: It's both.
In the sense, in general, what
we find is we have to go
through these various channels,
but since we are
actually signing up, say for the
Marketplace partnership,
if there is a special channel
where there is a dedicated
support, and we can get through
in e-mail, or some
other contact.
It's not just for billing.
I think billing and
provisioning is
one, but even otherwise.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: So it's
a great question.
It's an important topic.
I'll be the first to
admit that it's
not a simple process.
We've got, I'd say, a dozen
forums across different APIs,
including a main forum, which
is really for Marketplace as
in umbrella as a process.
So right now your best bet is
to engage with us in the
Google Apps Marketplace forum,
if it's some sort of question
around anything that's
non-API specific.
And then also engage with us
in the forums for APIs.
We don't have any other kind
of paid or per ticket
support right now.
But it's a request we
get a lot, so we're
thinking about it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Steph.
I'm a vendor in Europe,
in France.
And we are targeting a
lot of customers that
are not English speakers.
And I would like to know if
there is a plan to localize
the Marketplace for non-English
speakers.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Great
question.
There is a plan.
Unfortunately, there's
no concrete date
that I can give you.
But absolutely, we've seen a
huge adoption of Google Apps
and the Marketplace in all kinds
of countries that don't
speak English as their
primary language.
So even though we're global,
we're English only.
But we know that's not going
to serve our purposes.
So nothing to share in terms of
a date, but it's definitely
something that's a high
priority for us.
AUDIENCE: I have another
question.
What's the process for being
showcased on the admin panel
of customers?
Is it something that
we have to pay?
Or is it like you recommend
a the application?
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Yeah, I was
waiting for that question.
That's usually the first
question I get.
In general, there are two areas
where we're showcasing,
or where individual
applications are
being singled out.
The home page in the Marketplace
is the one, and
that's featured in notable.
That is an editorially
chosen set of apps.
And we look at things like
mainly customer adoption.
Customer adoption, reaction,
quality of the experience, and
we try to surface things that
we see are being adopted or
being ramping up in adoption
there first. So
that's the home page.
On the control panel and the
Setup Wizard, which I showed,
that's actually an algorithmic
decision.
So we'll have a recommendation
algorithm that basically looks
at things about the customer,
looks at the applications,
again takes all kinds of
signals like any good
recommendation algorithm
would.
But it's not a paid placement.
It's chosen by that algorithm to
basically try to match that
application with that user.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: All right.
Time for one more question.
Anyone else?
We've got a lot of brain
power and experience up
here for the panel.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me?
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So of the three
companies, is there any
preference on the language, like
say Python or JAVA, and
then external site is using
Google App Engine.
Do you guys have
a preference--
SCOTT MCMULLAN: The
question was--
Can you repeat the question--
AUDIENCE: The language between
Python or JAVA,
implementation wise.
And what was the difficulties?
JIM MCNELLIS: So what I demoed
today was Python, and our
current version is
actually JAVA.
That's part of the reason it's
taken a long time to
redevelop, so--
But both are on App Engine.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
CAMERON HENNEKE: And just to
point out, you don't have to
create your app on App Engine.
It can be on any kind
of platform.
And then the integration
is just that XML file.
I'm on Python, because I love
it with App Engine, but you
can do it on anything.
DAN STERN: And we're probably
the odd man out here.
We're actually running Ruby on
Rails at Amazon, and the
integration couldn't
have been easier.
We're up and running, I
think, in three days.
SCOTT MCMULLAN: Awesome.
Well, thank you all.
And thanks to our awesome
speakers.